what's the weather usually like in the
winter where you live
if you asked someone in fairbanks alaska
they might describe below freezing days
and navigating through huge drifts of
snow
if you asked someone else in miami
florida they might tell you that most
days it was warm enough to go to the
beach how can two places on the same
continent be so different
well it all comes down to regional
climates climate is the long-term
pattern of weather in a particular
region you can think of it as the
average weather
a region's climate depends on many
factors including its latitude elevation
and surrounding geographic features such
as oceans or mountains
let's look at how regional climates
depend on latitude first
latitude refers to imaginary lines that
measure how far north or south a place
is from the equator which equally
divides the earth in half the equator is
marked at 0 degrees latitude and the mid
latitudes increase north or south until
they reach the poles which are marked at
90 degrees north and 90 degrees south
the sun heats the planet unevenly so
places at higher latitudes which are
farther from the equator get less direct
sunlight and solar energy on average
resulting in lower average annual
temperatures
places at lower latitudes being closer
to the equator get more direct sunlight
and solar energy on average which
results in higher average annual
temperatures this uneven heating creates
a pattern of low and high air pressure
bands from the equator to the poles
affecting the amount of precipitation
that the different latitudes receive
in bands where moist air is rising
mainly at zero degrees latitude and 60
degrees north and south places
experience a lot of rainfall especially
around the equator
in bands where dry air is sinking like
at the poles and 30 degrees north and
south places experience very little
rainfall
this creates dry conditions at the cold
poles and desert conditions in regions
near the 30 degree latitude lines
another important influence on regional
climates is elevation or how high a
place is above sea level
as air rises from lower to higher
elevations it expands and cools
that's why regions at higher elevations
like mountains tend to have lower
average air temperatures than regions at
lower elevations
speaking of mountains and seas the
presence of geographic features can also
influence a region's climate let's start
by diving into the impact of water first
water heats and cools slowly while land
heats and cools quickly as a result
temperature variations tend to be much
smaller for cities near large bodies of
water than for cities surrounded by land
for example let's compare the yearly
temperature ranges for vancouver which
is close to canada's pacific coast and
winnipeg which is further east in the
interior of the country this line graph
follows the average temperature in
celsius for each city throughout the
months of the year
vancouver starts at the year mildly
chilly temperatures rise a bit for a
warmer summer and then slope gradually
back down overall the city sees a pretty
small range of temperatures throughout
the year because the nearby ocean
influences the local climate as it
gradually warms and cools compared to
vancouver winnipeg has a much colder
winter and a slightly hotter summer
resulting in a more dramatic range of
temperatures throughout the year we call
a climate like vancouver's a marine
climate and a climate like winnipeg's a
continental climate
things get pretty interesting when we
combine the impact of water with
landforms one unique example is a rain
shadow which can be found in places
where mountains are relatively close to
the ocean for example here's a satellite
image of the andes mountain range in
south america the mountains run north to
south in this image and they're close to
the pacific ocean notice how the area
between the pacific and the andes is
green and lush but the area behind the
andes is brown and dry that's the rain
shadow
what causes such a huge change
well when warm moisture-rich air from
the ocean meets the mountain it's forced
upward as it rises the air expands and
cools causing the moisture to condense
and fall as precipitation
now the air is much drier which allows
it to change temperature much faster as
that dry air descends down the other
side of the mountain it compresses and
quickly becomes warmer which leads to
increased evaporation
overall this results in a cool and wet
climate on the ocean side of the
mountain and a warm and dry climate
inside the rain shadow which is what we
saw on the satellite view
as you can see regional climates can get
pretty complicated when you consider all
of the factors that can go into them
depending on the exact region one factor
may be more responsible for the local
climate than the others like how the
presence of the andes mountains
contributes to the rain shadow climate
beyond them
let's look back at our two very
different cities from before so we can
see how the factors we discussed affect
their winter climates fairbanks is at a
very high northern latitude which helps
explain why it's so freezing in the
winter
miami is much closer to the equator and
near an ocean so it experiences a very
warm and mild winter which of these
cities would you like to visit in the
winter whether you prefer hanging out on
sunny shorelines or exploring frosty
winter wonderlands there's a regional
climate somewhere in the world that
you'd probably enjoy